disturbing new videos shedding light on
a deadly 2017 police shooting of a
teenager suspect as he tried to run away
their surveillance video shows very
clearly the 16 year old climbing a fence
and then falling to the ground after
being shot
now the teenagers parents are suing over
his death or lead national correspondent
David beg Noah was here now with more on
this story what are police saying
because a video does not look good
well so look it's all gonna come down to
this civil lawsuit and the jury is gonna
have to decide was the shooting
justified there were three different
separate agencies who investigated the
case and ruled the shooting was
justified they said at the time the
teenager who was unarmed
was suspected of murder but the family's
lawyer says just look at this tape April
15 2017 16 year old Isiah Marietta
Goulding leaps a fence and runs from the
police after a traffic stop he makes it
eight steps before an officer on the
other side of the fence pulls the
trigger and shoots him in the back of
the head Isiah crumples to the ground
police say there is more to this story
than just how it ended body cam footage
from one of the officers shows that it
started about a minute earlier when a
car that was driven by Isaiah's brother
was stopped at a shopping center both
had been suspected of a deadly shooting
that happened the day before Isiah takes
off running police start chasing him
across a road then over the fence and
that's when you can hear the fatal shot
sergeant ray Villa Bazo the officer
identified in the lawsuit as the one who
pulled the trigger said that during the
chase Isiah reached for his waistband
multiple times and that's why the
sergeant says he feared for his life
police say Isiah Marietta golding was
known to carry a gun and he was on the
grounds of a preschool when he was shot
the lawsuit which was filed by Isaiah's
mother claims that during the foot chase
Isiah never threatened an officer or
made any threatening gestures and that
nothing Isiah might have done justify
the use of deadly
Stuart Chandler is the family attorney
you can't say that every time an officer
fires a gun it's automatically okay
there has to be a line where you say
this is not acceptable and this is one
of those cases so the police in Fresno
say Isaiah is then 17 year old brother
who was in the car with him before the
shooting was arrested and pleaded guilty
to the murder the brothers were
suspected of committing but the family's
lawyer says that shouldn't matter here
well they just have to answer a lot of
questions look at the video he's still
running away and he's shot through a
fence David yeah from the back
a bullet shouldn't be used in a case of
pursuit it would seem to me but look
these are saying he looked like he was
grabbing his pants not grabbing his
waistband I guess when you're there on
the scene you don't know yeah there's a
lot of commotion on the scene like that
but it does appear he's just running
away it all come down to what the jury
decides the police say it was justified
right well 12 members of a jury agree we
shall see thank you very much David